watch this video let's go I'm gonna do
something a little different with these
final thoughts get a little bit more
personal if that's okay that last second
about hazing and fraternities got my
wheels turning it brought to mind
something I talked to my friends about
on a daily basis but until now haven't
really shared with you my viewers it's
not politically correct and actually not
even that political but it is important
is it just me or if men got really soft
these days whenever a woman says that
that's how I know that [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
and this has nothing to do with
sexuality by the way more so it has to
do with the helplessness of today's
young men it seems if you can change a
light bulb let alone fix a flat tire or
change oil and that makes for pretty
slim pickins for the females out there
looking for a match slim pickings out
there because a lot of men can't do that
[ __ ] then you better go back in the
kitchen and fix me a sandwich you [ __ ]
because a lot of you ladies can't cook
for [ __ ] what's up
Jewelry is all but dead and so is
business
and by the way wearing a flannel shirt
and having a beard doesn't make you a
man if you still can't change a tire and
you're scared of the dark and listen I
can't change a tire I'm not a lady what
you don't have a car how'd you follow
transform guess I'm not much of a men's
it seems like millennial men either
don't have jobs or they're still using
their parents credit cards to buy us
drinks at the bar oh and for the record
I buy my own drinks so who folded it
nobody was buying dreams [ __ ] are we
getting too strong no I don't buy that
see a real man knows how to handle a
strong woman so this isn't our problem
walk walk walk walk walk walk walk
well I
while the bleach gone to her head that
[ __ ] about real man handling real woman
what is there to handle what are you a
savage animal take it out of the zoo
digging out of the prairies of the I
don't know what what the [ __ ] is that a
real man nobody can handle me then you
got a problem if nobody can handle leave
that you need to be paying there's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] I look like Caesar
the [ __ ] dog whisperer I look like
Tarzan to you [ __ ] is there Milo you're
all these women that say that like oh
yeah I need a real man to handle me no
you crazy as [ __ ] you have a problem
your attitude is the problem if you need
to be handled my girl maybe it's the way
boys are raised these days fatherless
homes and no male role models it's hard
to learn how to be a man with no man
around
but even stable families are failing
belts please
teach your son's how to be men because
the women of the world are tired of the
boys women who say stuff like I need a
real man right and real well you know
what they're doing they're trying to
impose traditional gender roles on us
men try to make us live with the rules
of the past while not wanting to live
with them themselves
this summer I've said a million times
and this whole thing of life will be a
real man you imagine if I said be a real
woman get back in that kitchen cook me
that food learn to fold my clothes in my
laundry you wouldn't like that
whenever I hear a woman say be a real
man oh he's a real man I'm always
cringing on the inside Simon you're
apparently being sexist and you don't
even realize it now look I'm not saying
masculinity is bad I'm not saying he's
attribute your bet but I'm saying let
will be with the [ __ ] they want to be
learn about trying to influence us to be
things that we're not interested in yo
you know should be in the kitchen
everybody should be in the kitchen
there's food in there I should be in the
kitchen you should be the kitchen we
cook together and everybody everything
is all good when we eat we happy because
we
that meal if I got it if I got a change
if I got a change the tire you get me
that time but crank it up
teamwork [ __ ] that's what the
[ __ ] it is no oh you change the tire man
I'm not gonna lie to you after all this
laughing and giggling I've been doing I
kind of need to go make myself a
sandwich she last by maybe one to go
overboard okay hold up man let's go make
up you wanna you wanna send me that I
want to send this go makers hey man can
you pay for the sandwich I paid for the
sandwich you bring the sriracha let's go
all right so that's it for today's video
if you guys like that be sure to LIKE
subscribe Facebook YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main [ __ ]
follow us on Instagram all that good
stuff we got a patreon page so if you
want don't need a little bit money you
know give us a little thumbs up then we
do a little I definitely went the wrong
direction job but that's yes so you know
thanks holler a dollar makes me holler